I'm curious you guys get to like
interact with your fans at all or like
well we don't we don't do live shows or
anything like that we've done some
videos where we involved them like we
did a Christmas video where we delivered
uh yeah physical gifts yeah patrons yeah
yeah
um and we want to do some more kind of
stuff like that but yeah because we
don't live stream or anything it seems a
little difficult do you get like
recognized in the streets often and yeah
yeah okay yeah
I think I think they what they say to
Chad more that pisses him off than that
is uh
are you the fat guy from filthy Frank
on the channel so I don't know if
they're saying the joke oh yeah it was
kind of it's kind of it's kind of now
become this Blended thing where we
started making fun of there it's like oh
it's a [__] fat guy from joji so now
it's like people saying that because
they think that we think that's funny or
are they actually just saying that but
is most of your audience Australian oh
no it's America yeah yeah I think that's
just by the size yeah it's just you
can't really I think most
English-speaking channels yeah I guess
the Australian's already second right
because like mine's it's like yeah
is it 20 or something for Australia no
no it's okay because mine's like destroy
uh I think ours is like in general I
think it's just like
us then UK yeah USU oh that's right UK
UK is our second story and then I think
it's Canada then oh my God no one on
Australia watches you I guess yeah well
there's only 26 million people
how are we going to sell this stuff
United States 48.2 United Kingdom 11.8
oh now Australia 9.3 thanks 6.7 then
Germany but
what's your opinion on America have you
been [__] hate America
I hate Americans I [__] hate La I
[__] hate California Americans should
all [__] Yanks
what are your reasonings
do you know when you like you see a meme
where you're like oh Americans are like
really stupid and I'm dumb so this is
like coming from me this is like the the
kettle corn the pop black like you go I
go to America and I'm like okay you guys
are [__] stupid
like really dumb like your education
system everything about this country is
[__] and everyone there's like air
Freedom though we got our freedom and it
[__] exists like people like that
exist and it blows my mind
yeah I mean it's not our decision
anymore
no but there's a great place in America
I love Texas which is weird that I have
some on that road that's like the most
yeah
I I I I think California's left like a
like a foul taste in my mouth because
it's the only place in the world I've
been too many liberals in California you
can walk down one street and it's the
top one percent and then you walk past
the next street it's just pitch tense
and like oh and shits on the street and
it's everywhere it's such a like [__]
City and people say how much they love
it I'm like oh and like other YouTubers
like yeah I love living in California I
love it here I'm like absolutely every
YouTuber has just said yeah I don't like
living in California that's because
they're not rich if they're rich
YouTubers they live in the hills and
like I love it up here I'm like yeah
you're above the smog line that's why
you [__] like it because you can look
down on the poor people like like you
can also sort of see there's just no
soul behind the eyes yeah yeah they kind
of they're kind of always like looking
past you yeah
you tell them your followers just
understand them and they're like okay
we'll have a good day see you later
yeah I don't know Americans in America
just such a beautiful country that I've
been to some places yeah yeah it's so
nice when we're just done saying like
yeah this is the biggest like uh portion
of our viewers
right on Americans but I feel like the
people that watch us would also be like
yeah I [__] hate my country too well
I think the thing with that is people
often see content like that and they
don't ever associate it with themselves
they're like oh but I'm like the good
one yeah yeah I get what he's saying
that's so true
so what do you think about Australia
then
yeah
I think that's why um filthy Frank was
so popular with some of the stuff that
he would criticize as like a bit
everyone who was literally part of that
fan base which were the people they're
just making fun of were like that's so
true but that's not me but he was making
fun of those yeah so it's like the
weeaboo stuff and all you know it's like
yeah what has been a lot of weeaboos who
are watching him and referencing him
quoting him yeah yeah still in this day
so you feel like doing filthy Frank
things and I go to the Twitter profile
it's an anime picture I'm like anime is
cool now though anime anime is cool now
apparently I mean it's kind of cool
they're still very much different sex of
the anime community that definitely are
not cool like I don't know it's it's
also I mean to clown on anyone who has
an anime profile picture especially if
it's like a like a cute anime girl or
something yeah uh dragon ball fans as
well what'd you say Dragon Ball fans
[__] you yeah I'll I'll happily yeah
I'm not like
Dragon Ball Z workout it's like Goku
giving his power up speeches
two minutes on the treadmill bro that's
my power up bro you need to get two
minutes you need to get into JoJo then
man if you if you need something oh you
would [__] a lot I like the music
I just want to know if Kid Goku got
through that age
he literally had AIDS in the timeline he
had a heart problem he had a heart AIDS
or something
not every disease
there's nothing kill you slowly it's
AIDS
yeah I mean it's it's and he lost he
lost
in the timeline he lost in here yeah
that's one well you know what's [__]
up they could have raised aids with the
dragon balls but they didn't
[Applause]
that's on that bottom of the to-do list
we need a revive Goku we need to get
Krillin back
holy [__] is there anywhere in the world
though you haven't visited yet
because like one thing I've noticed is
that obviously like it's hard to travel
anywhere here in Australia because you
guys are so [__] isolated I don't I
don't mind the long hauls now a little
bit harder you know getting better so
but I yeah there are a lot of places
that I haven't been that I like to be
but I feel like I'm getting to a cynical
age very quickly where I'm like I
[__] hate cities I hate random people
on the street [__] talking to me you
need to go back to that uh little
fishing place that's where I want to go
I literally Countryside Japan as well
when we say end game I want to you know
launch Grog and I want to just like make
just enough money to be like okay I
don't have to worry about anything ever
again I'm gonna go to a [__] country
like in Iceland or somewhere like that
and like and just like get 10 dogs Farm
I always talk about wanting to like farm
and I I would love to be isolated if I
had good internet that's like the one
yeah which I think is possible nowadays
really my dream is like self-sustained
Farm
um where it's like minimum work for me
but I have people that live there and do
it for me
I think we always joke about oh wouldn't
it be awesome we had like a YouTuber
commune where we just yeah we just kind
of like the cloud houses but it's
literally like a commune like in a
[__] room you actually do well
because it'd be cheap we'd be able to
set up giant warehouses with shoes in it
for one tenth of the price yeah and I'm
just like you want to be a YouTuber
coming to [__] cold ones right yeah
get a get a house on the Block
was ranches I love that I'd [__] love
that [__] the high pass [__] these L.A
cold kind of sounds like how Epstein
started though okay cold runs Island
without the kids okay okay
what the [__]
have you seen that Meme where it's like
YouTuber when he gets 10 million Subs
with like the divided paths and it's
music yeah it's like shitty music career
or [__] molester child
not not that bad
oh my God but yeah end game would just
you know just enough
you should buy some like land in Japan
because it's actually like incredibly
yeah see here's another argument to that
I don't want to be labeled as that guy
like what do you mean that guy that
white guy that wants to go to Japan
you're not the first and you're not
gonna be like that story yeah it's like
I saw another speaking of memes we're
just talking memes I saw another meme
the other day and it's like a neck bed
and he's in New York and he's looking at
all the New Yorkers and he's a
capitalism scum and then it's like and
then it's him in Japan he's like oh
Japan
that's true but I don't I don't want to
be that guy like I can get a farm
anywhere I like preferably someone with
low tax brackets right Iceland okay
and that way and that way I'm like free
to like do whatever we want and not be
worried like obviously I'm worried with
the changes of YouTube If it all just
coming to an end ending because our
channel gets strikes good at that yeah
you got to diversify what you you can't
put all your eggs in my box yeah so I
mean I mean I I swear I think you guys
having a patreon is like a [__]
massive like it's the only thing that's
kept us going yeah right that and gamer
Subs Eric uh some games has been very
generous
what's the code
yeah it's just like one day and then
that way once I've got everything I want
yeah I'm a simple man I don't want my
fastest a few million dollars
that's self-sustainable
no I get it for a pretty good price and
you know I don't want a flash guy
driving Nissan Cube I'm a simple man how
about we just turn our patrons into Farm
hands 100 tier you can come live on the
farm and work for free pay us a hundred
dollars to get to milk our cow for us
and we get to keep the milk yeah you pay
a hundred dollars for them yes that
sounds good but that's essentially what
PewDiePie did I reckon that's where Mr
Beast is in a way yeah that's what R
Kelly did I reckon I reckon Mr Beast is
heading to the like uh Amazon type Town
sort of [__] Amazon Town yeah the
[__] Bezos had remember you don't
know about the
they basically just had a whole thing
that turned into everyone that worked
there oh that that's what that's what I
think he already I think he already has
that right yeah no yeah
I think Jimmy does have one yeah what
like he has like a cold apparently oh
that's a conversation
I think like the whole team has like an
entire row of like houses that they can
like rented out that makes sense make
like a small village I'm talking out my
ass this is I'm making this [__] up it
sounds from my from my knowledge and
once again is he does have a massive
property which is Warehouses on it yeah
where they go there and it's just a
ranch of warehouses and they film
business videos at the same time and all
the way he was ahead of the meadow man
he knew ranches was the way to go yeah
let's do it
is there any content that you want to do
in the future
like that you haven't done yet not like
buying like farmland or whatever we're
gonna go Japan but Japan we've done
something else related to traveling
which isn't out yet
[Music]
shout out to Prezzo for taking 100 years
I think six months he's had the footage
for
um but we've got we got it when I cut
myself we're cooking a video where we do
want to get out of the studio and travel
more and let him cook
for six months
[Music]
I know we feel that we sometimes we film
a special when it comes out like eight
months later or something like that we
definitely don't have that right we
definitely don't have that problem as
well
[Laughter]
there are other stuff we've talked about
doing but you know we're moving offices
at the moment because we're getting
bigger office yeah
um setting up a new studio we're hiring
new people we've got some new editors
starting so our goal is the video all
week and then be able to do stuff
outside the shooting travel related
videos we want to do a video where we go
to Japan and I listen I want obviously
there's a lot of there's a lot of things
we could do in Japan from a
from called one standpoint there's like
something it's like an interesting point
of content for you guys in Japan for
sure yeah it'd be fun to see I want to
recreate the Logan Paul vlog
Maybe
oh my gosh just one scene we're like
we're going to Japan and we have that
hello that's like an homage you know
it's filming an actual dude filming an
actual body that's too far
but it's funny
bad idea bad idea you gotta see the
conspiracy videos without like that was
scripted because the wind was blowing in
this direction on that day and the body
like going this way the sound other
people talking about the moon landing is
Logan Paul
even enough Force to give a [__]
still feel like we're feeling the
effects because if I if if he had like
made a full like
um like like turnaround where he's
actually a legend now and he's like like
he just can't stop [__] up yeah he
was so close over to a Redemption and
he's like a bunch of crypto scams yeah
which pisses me off because I've been
down he's totally fine again everyone's
just like yeah
so that makes me feel so good like I
can't get canceled like if that guy is
still [__] surviving you know what
yeah we just we just had to cut
something yeah okay if he can get away
with all the [__] he's done with like
that I I remember I used to wake up
every morning with anxiety I'm getting
canceled for something but I did last
week
now I wake up in the morning I'm like
you know what if he can get away with
that all right there is no way I can do
this is how evil starts
[Laughter]
I understand the the thing the point
you're coming from is like why should he
be able to get away with that well yeah
it's frustrating because you're like man
why should I have to hold myself exactly
exactly but there should be more thing
there should be better things holding
your morals in place then the next guy
can get away with yeah it's not about
what I've can get away with this like I
obviously will dual say something and I
have in the past and I've looked at it
like like you said when we're looking at
old videos we always go oh I wish I
never did that I could maybe get in
trouble for that one day I feel really
disappointed myself but I do have that
thought where I look at stuff I've done
the past and go I'm really disappointed
in myself that's not me anymore but then
maybe I will get in trouble one day
because the internet does like to nip
it's not it's not even just that that
times have changed and people don't like
that I know but my point my point is if
I ever got in trouble for it like 10
years down the line Because the Internet
likes to bring up this is who you were
you're bad for being that person yeah I
know you're completely different now but
[__] [__] you it's like if you can get
away with scamming people and like
double down and go like [__] you guys
you deserve to get scammed you should
have invested then I'm like man there's
no way I can get in trouble for saying
this stupid [__] I did well I I think I
can't get in trouble but yeah yeah I
think the reality is that just times
[__] change and a lot of people who
complain now about people's like
previous like Behavior or whatever the
[__] are soon going to realize 5 years
down the line there's going to be some
[__] that we're doing and saying yeah in
this day and age that's not going to be
socially acceptable in five years yeah
sorry finish with you yeah there's going
to be like some kind of clip or some
kind of tweet Instagram out there and
they're gonna realize oh [__] I was part
of the cycle is this this is a [__]
cycle they're at the stage in their
lives right now I think for the most
part where it's like they are either not
old enough or not experienced enough in
life where they've made those mistakes
themselves yeah yeah yeah and they
realize that that and you know making
mistakes and learning from it you know
years down the line and changing through
that is just like a natural part of
flipping growing up what sort of pisses
me off those people
don't even acknowledge that times have
changed yeah they're like you you said
or did this but it's like I said ordered
that because at that time I was pushing
the envelope only a little bit and it
was like it was maybe a little bit edgy
but it was now obviously fast forward to
here and that's so far behind the line
right yeah it's like it's not something
I feel I should need to apologize for
for a lot of that stuff it's just things
have changed and you don't like to admit
because it's like at the time it's like
how were you supposed to know that it
was going to go in the direction yeah
exactly like it's not cool now like
sometimes you can kind of like figure it
out just from like how societally you
know things are changing sure but then
there are a lot of times where it's like
how was I supposed to know that in 20
years time this word is bad now a lot of
the people that are taking those risks
and making things which made them
something because they were willing to
take those risks right if they were
super sanitized for the what everyone's
saying you shouldn't you should have
sticked stuck to this [__] script
they would have got to where they are
you wouldn't know who they were because
they haven't taken those parts to yeah
and now people that have survived that
are people because I actually did look
at their past they're like okay but yeah
then there are people that double down
just like kept doing it and then nowhere
to be seen now because yeah people
people should be able to look at it and
go okay I acknowledge that times have
changed I don't necessarily like
apologize for what
that was back then because things were
different but I understand
how culturally things are different and
that's you know I won't do it again yeah
or like I think it's better it's better
for me to go in this direction now right
and I'm supportive of this or that and
like we're all evolving together we're
all in this together
um yeah but like Chad said there's
probably people who'd go there oh it's
really it's really weird to me because
the internet like they strive for change
like all these movements are about
change and then they find someone who
has changed who has already acknowledged
what they've done the past is stupid and
they you know they've gotten better but
they still go back to the past to people
that have changed like [__] you like I'm
gonna ruin your life for somebody else
I'm like you're advocating for change
I've changed I've acknowledged that but
you're still getting mad at me like what
the [__] yeah yeah it's it's just
yeah they don't want what they want they
don't it's not what they think they want
they want to [__]
criticize which is what I actually want
that person to yeah they'll find any
excuse to just like tear down that
person because of a Personal Agenda or
whatever it might be even though as you
said like they want you to change on the
surface but then they still go out of
their way to like dig up Ultra and be
like huh see he was bad that's why I
just want to farm yeah
I don't want to think about me with
people on there helping me with it
there's some weed growing on the side
you know that's what I'm talking about
no internet out there
I want Farmers that won't be up
who I am